all right
sorry for the short delay and
get us started right now
see shubham
pandy is with us he is our expert
inspector in data science
my name is stuart creek i am
a marketing manager here at simply learn
and
we'll begin in just a second here as i
bring up the presentation
i'm just going to introduce
the topic and
show them
a little bit and then we'll turn it over
to him
so welcome everyone
to our data science master class
on regression analysis and its
applications as i mentioned shivan pandy
is our
expert instructor who's with us today
you can ask questions for shivam by
going into
the q a panel in webex
if you are on
social media linkedin or youtube
enter questions in the comments we'll
try to get those
and we'll be addressing those in the q a
section toward the end of the program
although he may
check the chat in the q a from time to
time in between
first i would like to ask
so that he has an idea who's in our
audience today
how much experience do you have and give
me a moment
well i
hold on a second
oh it's done this thing again
one moment
oh
i'll be back in just a second well i get
this
show them you may want to unmute
yourself
and introduce yourself to the audience
uh thanks stuart
uh hello everybody
how you doing
uh very excited and very happy to uh
e-meet you here
great
awesome
so
let me introduce myself
uh before we begin
just a second i'll share my screen
uh
you need to make me up
yeah i'll fix that just a second
uh
you have the sharing privilege i'm going
to launch the poll without the slides
uh give me more check if you can if you
can
view my screen my powerpoint
which i'm projected awesome
yes we can and again i apologize for
this uh difficulty we'll leave the poll
questions until later
no worries we all face these technical
problems let's get started now
so my name is shubham pandey
and i carry more than a decade of
experience around 12 years of experience
into
data science into machine learning ai
and my role in the corporate has been
into his strategy consulting
specifically into marketing domain
and i've been working with the top
management
uh and i've been helping them with data
driven insights
to build strategies to implement
strategies etc
uh i've always been passionate for
teaching so right from the beginning of
my career i have been
in touch with academics
at the very beginning i used to train
people over the weekend whenever i used
to get time and let me tell you at one
point of my career i was a full-fledged
corporate trainer
where i used to visit the premises of
different companies and i used to
deliver workshops on different
analytical tools and techniques
so these are a few corporates these are
few companies where i
uh facilitated workshops on analytical
tools and techniques like citibank hp
global natick services itc pwc
american express exchanger singapore
infosys cognizant circle group gender
talent auto live
indigo airline so
and i'm associated with multiple
institutes
organizations universities
and
with simply learn it has been the
greatest association i believe
more than six years it has been
and we are growing together
so this is a brief introduction about
myself you can always visit my linkedin
profile follow me over there
my subject matter expertise
right from the beginning of my career
i've been
using sas
if you leave for last few years
last few years have been the years of
open source tools but before that sas
was the market leader so most of my
career i worked on sas last five years
almost everything on python are spss
tableau i use extensively excel i love
and these machine learning techniques i
use as a part of my day-to-day work so
this is a brief introduction about
myself
should i get started with uh
regression
uh before we do let me open that poll
that i mentioned
sure
let's bring that up
uh
and the categories are abcd uh
if you have greater than five years
three to five years one to two years
or you're at college or university
category d
this is how much experience you have in
the workplace not just
not particularly in data science
we have a second question for people on
webex which is how you're doing today
we're checking in on your
uh
well-being during this pandemic see if
you're holding up to the
various surges and
lockdowns that come and go from time to
time
and here are the poll results
so
almost half of our audience have more
than five years of experience
we have
about the same number who are
either still in school or just out of
school one to two years of experience
and then
it looks like
90 of our audience is doing either well
or okay so
it's good to know that
most people are doing
all right during the pandemic here and
i'm going to go back to
show them to let you start the
discussion of regression
sure
so
let's get started
with our discussion for today
again a quick check if you're able to
see my screen
great
thank you thanks for the confirmation
so we all understand that uh
i'm not aware of your uh background how
much you know
uh
about
statistics
about mathematics
uh but i'll give you an idea about this
technique regression
i'll give you an idea about the use of
this technique
and
the mathematical
interpretations
to some extent
this will give you a very good idea
about statistical techniques
this will give you a very good idea
about the topics we discussed discussed
in the class
the methodology we use in the class
sometimes i have seen especially those
who are new to online training they have
apprehensions about the online training
methodology so this will give you an
idea about how we conduct online classes
so
yeah let's get started
i may be asking you questions so feel
free to
uh respond
uh share your thoughts share your ideas
okay and i will try to incorporate your
thoughts in our discussion i'll try
because it's a big audience so may be
difficult for me to incorporate
everything but i'll try
so how many of you
have heard about regression
in the past
any idea about regression
very good
okay some of you have heard for a few of
you it's a new idea
okay
great
thanks for your responses
it
so let me tell you a regression is a
very vast topic
okay and let me tell you i can easily
teach regression for six months
such a vast topic it is
regression
today we'll only get an idea about it
and i'm sure it will be fun
especially for those who are learning it
for the first time
or for those
who have some basic idea
in their academics they learned about it
so here there's a case
there's a business case
we are gonna
discuss first of all
so this case is about
uh
the part of the world where
there's too much cold
and we need
uh fuel
we need gas to
increase the temperature to heat
the places okay
so in order to predict weekly amount of
natural gas
that will be required to heat
at homes and businesses
in a city
based on week's
average hourly temperature
companies leverage a regression analysis
technique
so here
uh regression we are going to discuss
from the perspective of demand supply
gap
okay
so depending on
the past
demands of demand supply trend
we will try to establish
some relationship
we'll try to establish some patterns
and based on that
will be able to
predict
the demand
okay
does this make sense
so far so good
[ __ ]
so
let me tell you here what
we are trying to do
we are trying to look at
a few
previous
observations
and based on those previous observations
we will create a model
okay
so those previous observations
have been
described here in this scatter plot
which you see on the left hand side
so on the x-axis you have temperature
and on the y-axis you have got a fuel
okay so on the x-axis we have
temperature and on the y-axis we have
fuel
and these are the observations
so these are the past observations based
on these past observations
we will try to extract some patterns
we'll try to build a model based on that
so
there's a new term for you here
especially those who are very new to
data science
model
we'll try to build a model i just
mentioned
we'll try to build a model
can anybody tell me what is a model what
is a statistical model
can you tell me
any thoughts on that
what is a statistical model
uh a few responses i really appreciate
a few responses here i can really
appreciate
awesome
very good isaac
great
so statistical model uh
if i
attempt to explain to you
it is nothing but
generalized pattern
it is nothing but
generalized
patterns
you extract from the observations
is it making sense
i used
a few terms here generalized
patterns
you extract
from the observations
so patterns they should be generalized
which you extract from the observations
okay
in fact
a model is a kind of hypothesis
which you make
for the population with the help of the
observations
you have
is it making sense
so a model is a kind of hypothesis
model is a kind of hypothesis which you
make for the population
or the data generation
process
okay motor is a kind of hypothesis which
you make for the population
what is generalized some of you asking
what is generalized
so you see
from these observations you may get many
patterns
but we need to understand those patterns
we need to look into those patterns
which are significant
which are backed by
significant data
common patterns here
okay
so we spend a lot of time to find out
generalized patterns
okay so there are
mathematical
ways to get to generalize patterns there
are mathematical techniques to get to
generalize patterns
okay
there are ways
to get there okay
good so
we are good
absolutely hypothesis can be a true
hypothesis can be false
so you cannot say that this model is the
best in the world
absolutely
yes you try to validate it you try to
test it
with the help of unknown observations
so for that you need to create some
validation framework okay so it's a very
long discussion i told you
and i wanted you to realize this as well
that was also an objective
i wanted you to realize it as well
uh that how deep it is and what all you
have to do
great
let's go
to the next page
here
i kind of
written here a couple of lines
for regression analysis
it is a statistical technique used to
relate a variable of interest
to one or more independent or predicted
variables
so
whatever variable which we want to
predict which we want to analyze that
variable is called as dependent variable
okay and other variables which we think
are impacting the independent variable
the variables which we think
can
change
the variable of interest
those variables we call as independent
variables or they can also be called as
predictor variables because these
variables are used to predict the
variable of interest
okay so the objective here is to build a
statistical model
so that
we may
do these three things
we can describe
the variable of interest
we can predict variable of interest
and we can control a variable of
interest
okay so when we talk about regression
people generally think that it is only
about predicting
no
with the help of regression you can do a
lot many things
you can go into
granular analysis
and you can find out which variables
are more important which variables are
less important
for the variable
of interest
and then if you know that you can do the
description you can describe it better
you can control the variable of interest
better right
we are meeting here for
a few minutes
it's an hour's time
so difficult for
us to get
too much too deeper but yes
we have enough time to
understand the concept at least from the
perspective of uh
conceptual understanding
so
uh to make our discussion simpler
uh we will use only one variable
temperature
which we think can impact the fuel
okay
and we will try to
find out a linear relationship
between fuel and temperature
this is called as simple linear
regression
since we are trying to find out a linear
relationship that's why linear
and there's only one predictor variable
we are including here that's why simple
okay so simple linear regression is a
linear regression model with single
predictor variable
and we try to establish here a linear
relationship between dependent and
independent variables
okay so what we are trying to do here
i'll try to explain this to you
what we are trying to do we are trying
to establish here
a relationship
so we want a fuel
as a function of temperature
are you able to see what i am scribbling
here
okay since
we are confining ourselves to linear
regression so this function f
we are considering as linear
okay so if it is a linear function
then i can always write
this in the form of
uh
beta naught
plus
beta 1
into temperature
general equation of a line
right
do you remember y is equal to mx plus c
this equation
right where m was
slope of the line
and c
is y intercept
right
so we want to establish this kind of
relationship
why do we want this kind of relationship
because you see here
this beta 1 is slope
and this beta naught is y intercept
so we are able to find out the
appropriate values for beta naught and
beta1
then we will be able to achieve our
target
suppose we know beta naught and beta1
don't you think we can plug in here the
value of temperature and we can find out
the fuel
are with me
so if you are able to establish
such an equation
we'll be able to do the prediction very
easily we can just plug in here
temperature
we can plug in here temperature and we
can get the value of price sorry fuel
okay so this kind of relationship we
want to establish
something like this
we want to establish
so here the slope is
0.13 negative negative slope it is
and y-intercept is 16.
so this is 16
this one
this is 16
okay and what is slope by the way
what is slope of a line
so slope of the line is change in y per
unit change in x
right
if i make it very simple
it is change in y per unit change in x
so change in fill
if we change temperature by one unit
make sense
change in fuel
if we change temperature by one unit
that is your slope
okay i'm not getting into core
mathematics otherwise i
explain in detail
in my machine learning classes in my
data science classes
about slope
because we don't assume anything in the
classes
we always start from scratch
so
it is about the
tan of the angle
line makes with the positive x-axis
right that is slope
okay it is d y by dx
but uh
okay
so this is what we want to achieve
yes hitanshu you are absolutely correct
so i just explained here what we want to
achieve
we still don't know how to go about it
right
now we will go about it
so as hitanjo mentioned
how to establish such a line
how to find out such a line
because there are so many lines are you
able to see this slide but
you mentioned
here that there are so many lines
passing through these points
which line to choose
which line to choose
which line to choose out of so many
lines passing through the points
this is a question of million dollars
here
let's see
let's see how we choose
that line
here comes
an algorithm called
odd ordinary least square
algorithm ols regression
okay
how we choose
the line
let's see
so we first of all assume
a line
beta naught plus beta 1 x is equal to y
we all know
that only beta naught
and beta1
are variable
amongst the lines passing through these
points am i right
only these two are changing only these
two are the variables
so we assume this line
here
beta naught is the y-intercept and beta1
is the slope of the line
now we need to find appropriate values
of beta naught and beta1 to get the best
fit line
now when i say best fit line what does
that mean
best fit line will be that line which
gives me
least error
okay
so you can see here
this assumed line this hypothesized line
beta naught plus beta1 x
we have drawn here
which is cutting across these all points
these are observations
okay
so if i pick up any one observation
let me show this to you
just a second
if i
pick up any one observation
suppose i pick up this observation
okay suppose i pick up this observation
so you see
for this observation
temperature is this one x i
right
and the fuel is y i
okay
this is the observation we have
this we have recorded from the past
right
if we are using this line
the predicted value
don't you think will be this one
this is the predicted value
so this is the actual value this is the
predicted value
don't you think you always want
this distance to be the least
are you with me
you would always want
this distance to be the least this error
to be the least
this is called as
residual
this is called as
residual
this we want the least
okay so this is the idea
we want that line
for which
this residual value this error value is
least for all the points
okay so we want that line for which
these residual values are having least
value for all the points
let's come to the next slide
okay
so what will be
uh residual
the residual is
predicted by
let me i have to get into that mode only
because
i need to scribble here so presentation
mode does not allow me to scribble
so
the idea is
to find a line for which predicted y
at observed y
are closed for
all the points
predicted by
this value predicted by
what will this be
so this is the line
okay this is x i
and the equation of the line is beta
naught plus beta1
x is equal to y
so if i'm talking about this point
what will this point be
you will just plug in here x i don't you
think so so this point will be
this point will be
just a second
so this point will be
beta naught plus beta 1
into x i
are you with me
so this predicted y is nothing but
beta naught
plus beta 1 into x i
an actual value you know that is y i
so what is residual
predicted y minus
actual wise y
so it will be
simply predicted by minus actual y
actual y or observed y
so beta naught plus beta1
x i minus y i
okay this will be the residual
i want this residual this error to be
the least for all the observations
so what we do
yeah i'll do that again amit
just a second i'm trying to enlarge it
i hope this is visible
the fonts are big enough and i'm
scribbling here
fine
okay
so what i'm saying here
sure sure
what i'm saying here is
i'll explain again
just give me a minute
uh or let me take you to
my onenote
are you able to see my onenote
then here i'll be able to explain better
so you see here you have fuel
here you have temperature
right
and these are your observations
what i am saying is
there are so many lines passing through
these points
there are so many lines passing through
these points i need to choose
the best fit line
so we are in search of a best fit line
what we do for that
we first of all assume this line
this we call as hypothesized line or
assumed line we assume it we still don't
know about this line let's call it
unknown line
but for unknown line as well i can write
the equation
beta naught plus beta 1 x is equal to y
where y is fuel and x is temperature
okay
if it is the best fit line then what i'm
saying is
for any point if i take any point
this point if i take this for this point
suppose temperature is x i
and a fuel required is y i
so this is actual value of fuel right
these are the observations these are the
points given to us these are the data
points which we have captured from the
past so this is actual value
actual value of y
actual value of fuel
what will be the predicted value
this will be the predicted value
what will that be
we'll just plug in the value of x i here
beta naught plus beta 1 x i
that will be the predicted value now you
are clear
so this error we want minimum
for all the data points
those who are asking me to repeat are
you not clear
so beta naught
plus beta 1 x i
this is the predicted value
you are subtracting
actual value y i
from it
this is your residual
this is
residual
or error
okay
this you want minimum for all the
records this wants you minimum for all
the data points
okay
so what you do
you aggregate this value for all the
records
you aggregate this for all the records
right
so you take
the square of it
and then you
find out the summation
so if
there are
huge
ah
a set of
records
we have tools to take care of that
why we take the square
let's try to understand that
this value
may be negative
this value may be positive as well right
this residual may be positive maybe
negative
are we interested in the algebraic sign
of it
are we interested in that
the answer is no
we are only interested in the difference
we are only interested
to understand
how far
predicted value is from the actual
we are only interested here to know
how far predicted value is from the
actual that's that's what we want
okay
we don't have to take the square root
because we only want this to be minimum
right
so this expression
we want
minimum
right
let's go back there
so here i have written we need to find
out
now one more thing here let's go back
there
this is an expression we have gotten
summation
beta naught plus beta 1 into x i
minus y
i squared
okay so this expression we have gotten
we are taking the square here
instead of mo or mod
because square is more conventional and
easy to work with
okay
we can take mod as well
if you want to avoid only those
algebraic signs
you're right but we take a square here
just to make our calculations much
easier
and also for one more thing
also for one more thing
uh
you
see what we are going to do here we are
going to
minimize this expression are you with me
weather
and viraj we are going to minimize this
okay can you tell me what are the
variables here in this expression
on which basis we will minimize it
what is unknown here in this equation
no x i and y are no are knowns
come on
those are the observations
right
so here we have
beta naught and beta1
known we don't know about
beta naught and beta but don't forget
that
so here unknowns are beta naught and
beta1
these two are unknowns
now
you see we need to minimize it for
minimizing what we do
do you remember maxima and minima in
differential calculus
we need to find out the first order
derivative
and we equate that to 0
right for that to happen we should have
this function differentiable
is mod function differentiable
you get answer to your question now
so i'm not getting into the details of
core mathematics here
i'm not getting into the details of
mathematics here but
you need to understand here we minimize
this
we minimize this and find out the
appropriate values of beta naught and
beta1
okay so we find out the beta naught and
beta1 for which this expression is
minimum
right
so we find out
beta naught and beta1 for which this
expression is minimum
that's how we find out
the best fit line are you all clear
i tried to
explain this in detail
without knowing your background and all
i try to make it very simple for you
okay
this is probably like the last slide
just a second
differentiation is done with respect to
beta naught and beta1 it will be a
partial differentiation
okay
so we differentiate
with respect to beta naught and beta1
partial derivative we find out
so let me tell you we don't have to
manually differentiate it
we don't have to do that manually
we have amazing tools
we have great libraries
okay so direct functions are available
which can do everything for us
okay
for machine learning
for bigger data sets we have better
optimization techniques
okay
anyways coming back here
yeah gradient descent and
gradient descent is one basic technique
we have a better variance of gradient
descent optimization like adam optimizer
and all
okay so
we have very good optimizers
which can help us to
work with huge data sets
great
how good is regression
this is the next question we have
created a regression model now we want
to understand how good good is that
okay we have been talking about best fit
now how how good that fit is
okay for that purpose we perform this
analysis
okay
so you see here we compare
just a second
i would need to go back into that mode
only
we do here
in this way
so we
draw here
this line horizontal line for mean of y
okay
this value is the predicted value of y
this value is the observed value of y if
you are talking about this point
okay
so suppose you are using
mean to estimate the value of
fuel
suppose you are using mean to estimate
the value of fuel
don't you think this much is the total
deviation
if you are not using regression
you are using simply the mean of fuel
to estimate
fuel
this much is the total deviation
right but if you're using regression
if you're using regression
you are able to predict
with this number
okay so don't you think regression
has taken you
closer to the actual by this margin
am i right
total margin was this much
if you're using regression you
approached closer
to the actual
this closer this is called as
explained deviation
explained by
explained by
whom
who explained this
the regression absolutely
explained by the model explained by the
regression
so this is the plane deviation
okay
and what is this part
this part is still unexplained
despite using this amazing technique you
are not able to reach exactly at the
observed value
right so this much
even regression is not able to explain
so this is called as unexplained
deviation
right
so
y i minus y hat
y i minus y hat is the total deviation
y minus y hat
y i minus y hat it is unexplained and y
i hat
minus y bar is x plane deviation
okay
this you find out for all the
observations and you aggregate
before you aggregate you know you have
to take the square
this you call as total sum of square
this you call as
error sum of square
this you call as a regression sum of a
square
okay
just a second why do you use mean as a
reference to calculate the deviation
from regression actual okay
a very good question ricardo
so if you need to
find out
the value addition by any new project
by any new initiative
okay in your organization suppose you
have taken an initiative and you want to
find out the value added by that
initiative what do you do
you always take a reference point
right
you always need to find out a reference
point
for that
we are using mean here
so if you don't know regression
if you have no idea about regression it
simply means that you are not able to
relate the variables
you are not able to find out the
relationship between the variables and
if you are not able to find out the
relationship between the variables you
will only depend on
the values of that variable of interest
only
and then you will use mean for the
estimation
right
uh maybe using t statistic or z
statistic
okay
so that's what you do
so we have
scarcity of time here
uh so i need to quickly cover this slide
and i want to make sure i explain this
slide as well
very well
i want to give my best at least
so once we determine the linear
relationship now the question is how
strong the relationship is
for that purpose what we do
we find out this ratio ssr
to sst
this we call as r squared
okay
higher the value of r squared
we call that model we call that
regression
a better fit
okay
but there are
many
other aspects here as well
okay r square if goes too high
then also it is a problem
so for that purpose we look into
something called adjusted r squared
okay so there are a lot many other
things here
i told you regression is a very vast
topic
but i tried to give you
an idea about
regression
uh i'm sure this will give you a good
starting point even if you want to learn
on your own
this will definitely give you a platform
to take off from
do you agree with me
so you guys gave me your precious one
hour
and i hope
i was able to add some value
uh thank you so much
uh uh this is all i have
for regression
um
later some other day
all the best for your learning and for
your career
and i'm going to go ahead and
close out the session with a few
uh concluding slides
so thank you very much shubham for the
great session on regression
and
thank you
a really good
example of how this type of uh
teaching happens
we have a learning management system in
which
this type of thing
instructors like shubham
work with you and
where you can manage your progress with
the courses you can
do
other types of
self-study material for some of the
courses
and
we have a number of programs for data
science certificate certification
some that are six months some that are
longer
they are all partnering programs uh
online boot camps that
only take 10 to 15 hours a week
of effort that includes live virtual
classrooms with instructors like shubham
um
interaction with your peers the other
students who are enrolled with you
they provide a comprehensive curriculum
with an industry-aligned learning path
so they're designed to train you
for the types of challenges that you
face
in doing actual work in data science
data analytics
they include integrated labs and
hands-on projects so that you can do
exercises like the one shivam
demonstrated to you
where you get the data set and determine
what the best fit line is using the the
tools provided
that's all
uh in online
access so you don't have to
buy
any specialized software for it or
have a separate system for it it's all
through your browser um
so it's all very flexible and allows you
to fit that into your work schedule
some of the tools that
you learn in these programs
from python language to
numpy and scifi libraries to tableau for
data visualization
um are all included in the various
courses it's uh they're designed
programs are designed in a stepwise
fashion
to take you
from
the
introductory level all the way to
uh
advanced topics like machine learning
what you end up with is a certificate
which may be issued by cert simply learn
or may be issued by one of our
university partners depending on which
program you choose
there's
usually dozens of labs projects
and an all-important capstone project
that lets you demonstrate
all of the skills you've learned in one
integrated
industry aligned project
most of our programs include job
assistance of various types for students
who are in india or in the united
states um
so i just wanted to mention those
uh sherman do you have time for the
questions and answers
i want to see if he's still here
uh yes stuart i'll be happy to answer
the questions
okay i just have a few we don't have
time for for too many but um
first off i want to give you a shout out
from mark uh who says he he took your
python for ds class as complete beginner
in 2018
he was over age 50 at the time
um
he had no cutting background no computer
science background
uh and he
is uh
since he's completed that course with
you he's taken
machine learning and
karis
he
really
uh thanks you a lot for
his learning and his his progress so i
wanted to give that um
because he's
i'm sure he wanted you to know that
um
so
here's a fundamental question from ajaz
who says
a hypothesis can be true or false
but a model is just a way of arranging
the data elements in a specific manner
is that correct where is that
absolutely
okay hypothesis may be true it may be
false
we try to validate it the the best
possible way but still
we are never sure as to
uh
this model is the best possible model in
the world we just can't say always and
for this i would like to
tell you that you should go for free
lunch theorem
okay so you can refer to that theorem
you can read
that theorem that will help you to
understand it better
no freelance theorem
the no free lunch theorem okay
um
nitish asks if the regression method of
estimation is the same as
regression analysis
yeah absolutely so two terms for the
same thing yes yeah
um
when
siddhant asks a question what happens
when the data itself is not
not sure of its accuracy
what what
what are the ways to deal with that
so if you're not sure about the accuracy
of the data
now you need to understand that the
model you create with the help of that
data only so if there is a problem with
the base data only obviously the pattern
which you will
figure out the patterns which you will
extract from that data though that those
patterns will not be reliable so the
model which you will create will not be
reliable for sure
so you should have the same expectations
from the model as well the expectations
which you have the knowledge which you
have about that data
if you know that the data is corrupt or
data is having bad quality so you should
have the same expectation from the model
excellent
um and
when we go past the the
notion of
linear
regression or when you've modeled
the data and you've found that it's
not
modeling
reality correctly what are some of the
other
steps you take to create a better model
absolutely it's a good question and we
spent a lot of time to understand this
part
how we can fine tune the model how we
can make the model better how we can
create a model
which performs better on the unseen data
points
so
the answer to this question uh cannot be
summarized in a couple of lines
uh it is a detailed answer and this
there's a process we follow for that
and the last question i'll take is from
amit which is
what's the effectiveness of these kinds
of courses i've described here
if your objective is to reach higher
management and
if you want to get into
you know director level cxo level types
of things is are
is this kind of data science training um
helpful so it's a very good question
and
let me tell you
uh if you uh are
at a
very
i mean senior position even then this is
going to be very helpful for you because
we are in the we are in the era of
data explosion and all the decisions
nowadays are taken based on data so you
may not have to write the programs on
your own you may not have to clean your
data but you should be able to at least
interpret
the important matrix
right
so uh at the optimum level you should be
aware of the terminologies you should be
aware about the metrics which are used
here
okay
so it is important that will definitely
give you an edge
because even if you are a ceo of a
company you need to justify your
decision to the to the chairman
so if you are able to justify your
decisions
backed by data
nothing like that
just answers
yeah
um so i'm gonna ask another poll and
hopefully this will work better than the
last time i tried to
do this
hopefully you haven't frozen yet
i say that
and i'm frozen so hold on a second
apologize for the instability of my
system
again i apologize for that
issue let's fix that
apologize
say that we have a
next webinar coming up one week from
today
data skills for non-data scientists you
have people who know that
are looking to add data science into
their work
and they're not
in the
data science field directly
for them to us for this i will try to
put into the chat the
link to this particular webinar
if that works
okay
my deepest apologies this system is
giving me a lot of troubles
but i will try to put into
the chat that
link to the
next
webinar in the meantime thanks to
everyone
for
joining us today
we do ask you
to
follow us on our
social media channels
at simply learn
on facebook and twitter
and simply learn on linkedin
and
that concludes the webinar
so thanks again all of you for being
here and thanks to shubham
for this
really wonderful presentation
thanks stuart for all the support and
hosting it thank you
take care everyone
you